earlier this month we announced that
karaoke and open mic events are allowed
to resume
under the new safety guidance here in
our state christian that's right well if
you're looking for something fun to do
why not sing your heart out
rocky theaters is live inside the grand
canal shops at the palazzo
where you can make all your karaoke
dreams come true safely and in style
we are singing safely on the strip is
what i'm saying today because
as as you mentioned earlier this month
we actually are allowed to do karaoke
again and you guys i want to introduce
you to evan because
he's the reason why you're the man so
tell us how you did it
uh well we worked very hard with the
governor and clark county commission
and helped work through these safety
protocols which were just recently
approved and very excited to have
microphones oh my gosh
i'm excited this is my first time doing
karaoke in vegas so
show me how do i do it safely first of
all you have to get your temperature
scanned so you can put your face in
there
it checked your temperature you're at
97.3 stand there the door for three
seconds to get uvc sanitized door
okay two three and you walk through boom
all right follow you
thank you and now we enter kamu
ultra karaoke experience let's talk
about this space this is the common area
so what's the capacity like how are you
what is it looking like now between 6
p.m and 8 a.m because they're open
until 8 00 a.m guys yeah it's very very
late uh
the restricted capacity is now 266
people from
covid uh so each room averages uh five
plus people for each room okay
so speaking of rooms let's head into
inside of them because this place you
guys i mean
obviously karaoke bars are pretty
standard you know what to do but this
spot in particular is extremely unique
each room
the interior design is spectacular
customized with a different concept
oh there we go i had i had our guy seven
get my get my song ready for me play
yeah so we're playing a little bruno
mars in here anderson park's new song
leave the door open i feel like this is
going to be the new hot karaoke song now
so tell us what room we're in evan okay
so i
also would bring in a colleague of mine
here to talk a little bit about the room
oh wait no i'm sorry he doesn't have a
mic on oh he doesn't okay
but we'll get to him we'll get to him
we'll talk about the vip experience
later in the show but okay
so we have 40 40 different rooms here
uh there's six vip rooms yeah each of
them has
its own concepts uh this is a very
egyptian themed room um
and this is some examples of things on
the menu uh we
are we have things like wagyu sliders we
have
uh maine lobster sandwiches tomahawk
steaks
and then we're introducing sushi coming
up in may so we're very excited to
expand the menu and offer more of an
experience
singing and sushi you really can't ask
for more than that but i want to talk
now
especially about how you can be inside
of a room and singing safely with your
friends
okay we have the mic i'm gonna pass you
one here absolutely
obviously so you have 100 mic but
something's different
disposable mic covers so each
room has disposable mic covers we have
thousands of an inventory they just
replace them
with each experience the guests are
actually allowed to come in
uh they can allow to remove their masks
from their uh
dance and uh i'm sorry when they sing
uh drink yeah i feel like it would have
been difficult to do karaoke without the
mics
correct exactly so i know you guys are
so excited to be back
and coming up later we're going to talk
to our guys somebody here who is the vip
healthy
the luxurious side to karaoke here at
common i'll send it back to you
wow that looks like a lot of fun
open till 8am oh they know how to party